You might wonder why we should care about negative space and
its relation to data visualization.
And well, we should pay attention to negative space,
because it communicates something about our data.
Let's look at two examples.
This first one explores the London's cholera outbreak in 1854.
John Snow documented deaths around the community to determine what might be
the cause of the epidemic.
He created this stop map by recording the location of each death by a bar.
The height or the length of these bars indicate that more deaths occurred in
a particular location.
Knowing this information, I'd like you to answer a question.
Which of these locations have no recorded deaths?
You can use the map that's linked in the instructor notes to figure it out.